we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question about Trump and his
helicopter take a listen to this I was
just wondering can you figure out why
did Trump stand outside with a
helicopter running all the time while
he's talking to the press you know I
mean I don't get it is he trying to look
like I'm flying all around I'm so
important there's always a helicopter
waiting for me why does he do that stand
out there and yell what Cady go out
there when the helicopters not chopping
around and the wind isn't blowing yeah
so listen this is partially a power move
on Trump Trump likes it yeah I'll throw
you a bone by being willing to talk to
you while my helicopter waits with the
rotors spinning in the background part
of it is that reporters wait to try to
get Trump to answer their questions on
the walk from you know the White House
or wherever over to the helicopter so I
think it's a combination of things and I
understand that when it's so hard to
actually get Donald Trump to answer
questions you'll take any opportunity as
a reporter even with a with the
helicopter blades whirring in the
background but you can tell Trump just
absolutely loves it and does see it as
as a sort of power move we'll talk on
the bonus show today about Donald Trump
a mocking teen climate activists Greta
tune Berg foon Berg I'm not exactly sure
how to pronounce her name we will talk
about Trump mocking her we will talk
about Indonesia raising the minimum age
for brides in an attempt to maybe end
child marriage and much much more become
a member and get instant access to the
bonus show by signing up at join
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show